almost 2 years after the slap her round
the world Jada pinget Smith is speaking
out about both the incident and her
marriage to Will Smith while promoting
her new book worthy which hit shells on
October 17th pinket Smith sat down with
people to reveal something huge about
the viral Oscars moment where Will Smith
slapped presenter Chris Rock after rock
made a joke about pinket Smith's shaved
head pinket Smith lives with alipa and
chooses to keep her head shaved as a
result needless to say a g joke made by
Rock didn't go over well Smith famously
followed up the slap by telling Rock
quote keep my wife's name out your mouth
according to pinket Smith she simply
assumed the situation was a planned bit
and was just as shocked as anybody to
discover that Smith actually slapped
Rock in Earnest she told people I
thought this is a skit I was like
there's no way that will hit him it
wasn't until will started to walk back
to his chair as I even realized it
wasn't a skit the moment was definitely
shocking and it led to huge consequences
for Smith so it's an added surprise to
hear that pinget Smith was apparently
baffled by it too she also revealed that
the first thing she asked Smith
following the ceremony was simply are
you okay that moment when Will Smith
slapped Chris Rock back in March 2022
was incredibly confusing at first in
fact several feeds of the ceremony went
completely blank as networks panicked
but when the dust settled all hell
really broke loose shortly after in rock
Smith got up on the stage to accept his
award for best actor for his role in
King Richard a film about Venus and
Serena Williams father Richard Williams
the anointed winner then gave an
extraordinarily tearful speech and
received a standing ovation however
Smith started facing major consequences
almost immediately when I opened my eyes
I didn't realize like why is everyone so
quiet like I literally was not present
for that whole entire moment Not only
was there reporter Le an argument over
we thre a not to kick Smith out of the
ceremony on the spot but Smith also
resigned from the academy he'd been a
member since 2001 and was eventually
banned from the ceremony for 10 full
years in response Smith released a
simple brief statement that said I
accept and respect the Academy's
decision Smith's next movie emancipation
barely made a splash when it came out in
2022 and a sequel to his Netflix
original movie bright was cancelled
Smith may have walked away from the
ceremony with a statuette for best actor
but the effect the slap had on his
career still feels irreversible Rock
meanwhile took some time to comment on
the slap but ultimately address the
incident in a Netflix standup special
titled selective
outrage the people like did it hurt it's
still
hurt I got summertime ringing in my
ear Jada pinket Smith had one last bum
shell to drop in her people interview
even though Will Smith implored Chris
Rock to keep his wife's name out of his
mouth the couple has actually been
separated since 2016 pinket Smith told
people after revealing that the two were
long separated at the 2022 Oscars we're
still figuring it out we've been doing
some really heavy duty work together we
just got deep love for each other and we
are going to figure out what that looks
like for us with that said she also
clarified that she and Smith are there
for one another as much as they can be
regarding the slap and just
ramifications pinket Smith said I'm
going to be by his side but also allow
him to have to Fig get this out for
himself piget Smith's Memoir which might
give people even more insight to her
marriage and the infamous SLP comes out
on October
17th